salve a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video che però non ho le
cuffie potrei non sentire questo è un
problema
teoricamente potrei anche vedere
perfetto bunt ain garden sarebbe il
giardino del buon tempo in italiano con
raggiunto questo è però non ho ben
capito cosa dovrebbe essere però visto
che una figata quindi merita però
madonna 4 profonda st intro cos'è
c'era una volta nella terra dei babbuini
march un albero che sembrava i miei
nervi quando faccio le verifiche di
matematica un elefante che vomitava
queste sono le cose che succedono quando
beve tè troppo ragazzi non bevete che
poi un casinò sono nato dal vomito
che bella la storia della mia vita bene
ma ho un pene che bello mi possono
imitare sul pene è una cosa eh beh ma
non credo sia educativo sul gioco però
posso prendere le robe per terra no
posso vomitare sulle robe per terra no
possono picchiare le robe porterà
slancio anche un culo beh ovvio
salve che bello devo fare qua devo
mitare far crescere sabbiato a
commettere la ringrazio sono un nano che
bello ci sono dei funghi nostrani che
posso provare a prendere nuovi cibo vito
sopra ivo minar e sopra le cose ragazzi
la soluzione a tutti i problemi fatelo
questa cosa non la sapevo dall'inizio
veli a quest'ora avrei fatto molto
avvistata nella vita salve vuole un po
di questo no intendevo questo sono
difficili come di soggiorno prova a
portarle dei funghi aspetti lì credo
c'entrino qualcosa i funghi perché se mi
fa un po strano che non sia riuscita a
far niente ancora quindi sicuramente
devo prendere
o forse ci devo mitare sopra poi
prenderlo ecco signora o fungo buono per
c'è un fungo per lei
ecco tenga
capire ok perfetto che non c'è un tasto
rilancio qua è un gioco
è ingrassata sa ai while you better non
stop
meglio che non ti fermi adesso sì però
stai calma grazie rilassata un sacco
vedo delle pop e uscire e facciamo qua
raccogliamo le poppe no poi mi chiamo
non so se si può definire family
friendly sto gioco perché c'è un pene
all'aria però non è un pene molto bene
un pene piccolo c'è un è un pene
indiscutibile ecco aperti invece è
rotondo capelli avanti chi se ne frega
vedo che gli alberi mi osservano
chissenefrega bongiu ma lei è un uccello
grosso stavolta cosa che voi da me che
sono un uccello dal mio nuovo e non lo
so neanche io però sto gioco quale
strano quindi qualcosa vorrà perché sei
seduto su una pizza
anzi non si ha neanche salutato le ho
fatto crescere l'albero è contento se
sotto effetto di lsd sto gioco no mostri
quelle robe
mi scusi ma al canale fermi frelli
questo lei lo sa ma come si permette ma
guardi lei ma ma non ho capito che sta
esce il bene o l'ovetto posso farlo
ricrescere che è successo chi è questo
lei è veramente brutto a me l'ha fatto
un altro grazie importante che io porto
l'ho detto a destinazione premio premio
signora su tornato guardi eccolo tutto
per lei c'è un nuovo per lei signor ac
muovo per lei ai logo ypsilon allora
litri tdi sono i capitoli va bene va
bene penso che chiaro
[Musica]
io non ho capito ci sono cose nella vita
che non sono spi questa non è spiegabile
ragazzi questi non so cosa dirvi andiamo
avanti ragazzini buongiorno ho trovato
questo non so cosa sia buon appetito
mangia tutto lei è uscito un momento non
sostenere quanto perverso è un po mi fai
passare la sua destra grazie molto
gentile bello se già comunque c'è un po
strano però è un misto tra perverso e
strano attraverso lei ha un sacco di
addominali lo sa a grazie lo prendo in
prestito grazie mi serve perché devo dar
da mangiare a una tizia che ha fame però
grazie mille quindi tutto sta il gioco e
centra incentrato sul dato da mangiare a
sta tizia alle varie cose che trovo in
giro ok va bene
l'appetito zia buon appetito tutto tuo
gli stanno uscendo un sacco di brufoli
tutto questo so young and fresh siamo di
sopra c'è un albero qui sono sull'albero
vado sulla roccia una strada con torta
non diciamo la parola torta sono cosa si
mangia pure quella pure la torta ok stia
fermo ci penso io a liberarla le vomito
un po addosso veda come facile a posto
ci penso io lei venga è un gioco facile
nel senso che l'obiettivo è chiaro ci
pensi sia tranquillo ci penso faccio io
faccio io che avevo persone che possono
aiutare ecco che questo è l'ultimo mi sa
che non c'è più strada appetito
meglio che non ti fermi adesso è ormai
non c'è più strada lo posso più
ma non c'è più niente da mangiare me
stesso no bisogna fare non c'è più nulla
ho preso tutte le strade sabato dal dal
dall'uccello da quello di prima torna
indietro non so forse c'era un'altra i
quattro cerca verna non l'avevo vista
c'è un'altra strage un tunnel fortissimo
buongiorno c'è di clet sembra buona kakà
gigante prova niente giorno la prendo in
prestito
non ho capito cosa dovrebbe essere un
panettone venire da straniero
mica sei nutella biscuit rimangi che un
piacere everson web quanti capitoli
esistono ho fatto di tutto dove devo
anche cosa vuoi
ok ma l'avevo previsto questa strada
nuova
andiamo a portare da mangiare alla zia
certamente io sono del libero questa è
questo questo gioco ed ex trending devo
portare salve posso dubitare sul sole no
che peccato
anch'io sono nato dal vomito il big bang
di data ragazze tutto nato da uno sbocco
questa cosa voi non lo sapete però visto
disco io lo dico io
c'è un culo a no
bravo lo faccia chi ogni tanto che
quando faccio il bagno dami rubare le
idee sulla parti culo
lo so che ti piace lo so che ti piace
posso prendere uno di voi prestito tipo
così posso prenderlo ha detto posso
vedere il tuo culo per culo
mi stanno dando di uomo buco di culo
basta chiamarmi popoli culo
allora per ora che mia mamma non mi
sente più registrare i video sono a
quest'ora sarebbe lì a farsi domande
alle e mi seguono mi seguono
perché un culo mi seguono soli
io pensavo di poter riprendere
raccogliere ok quindi viene seguiti per
con culo seguimi mi sembra avere il culo
oggigiorno è una qualità che noi tutti
stiamo andando in vacanza esatto ieri
come vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni ti
presento un amico eccola vieni qua top
come faccio da vila mangiato
eccolo è esplosa quello ma don tina casa
succedendo aiuto
intanto sono io che mi sto muovendo
vuole mangio io mangio e mangiami
mangiami mi sacrifico bar o tanto si
chiama james carr batte il creatori del
gioco bat signori questo era dei good
thing harlem
[Musica]
ok il gioco profondo fino allo stomaco
un bel gioco
complimenti viva i culi iori spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto un bacio se
avete un bel culo cha fatevelo ogni
tanto io concludo quale episodio
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate la
campanelline up rimanere aggiornati sui
video perché non potete perdervi questi
contenuti grazie di essere ridotto
ancora e noi come sempre signori ci
vediamo al prossimo video per ragazzi
[Musica]